bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir comment stopper l'ascension de
Marine Le Pen bonsoir aqu kilino Morel
et merci d'être notre grand témoin ce
soir vous publiez la parabole des
aveugles chez grassa c'est un essai
passionnant percutant aussi sur la
favorite de 2027 et les raisons qui la
place aujourd'hui aux portes du pouvoir
la charge est très violente notamment
sur la gauche votre famille politique
vous nous direz s'il n'est pas trop tard
tout à l'heure dans la 2uxème partie
notre grand débat ce soir l'extrême
droite à l'assaut de l'Europe la
victoire éclatante du parti pour la
liberté de gtvilders au Pays-Bas
confirme la poussé d'un courant
anti-immigration et anti-islam sur tout
le continent Italie Hongrie Slovaquie et
maintenant Pays-Bas la progression des
populistes vont-elle va-t-elle et bien
renverser la donne au prochain scrutin
européen de juin nous en débattons dans
un tout petit instant avec mes invités
enfin ns AFF franchi ce soir le billet
d'humeur de l'avocat bertranrier le mot
de la semaine de Mariette d'égrand et
puis action planète la chronique écolo
signée Léa Falco voilà pour le menu on y
va à kine Morel ça vous regarde c'est
[Musique]
parti jusqu'o la vague populiste en
Europe il était le favori mais le
triomphe de girt wildilders au
législative au Pays-Bas est un choc son
parti le PVV est largement arrivé en
tête et risque de peser lourd sur la
recomposition des rapports de force en
Europe bonsoir Laurent Geoffrin bonsoir
merci d'être là avec nous ce soir vous
êtes le directeur du quotidien en ligne
le journal info on connaît bien votre
signature longtemps patron de libération
et de l'OPS bonsoir yel Goose bonsoir
ravi de vous retrouver éditorialiste et
chef du service politique de franceinre
bonsoir Richard bonsoiram Richard verli
visage familier de cette émission vous
êtes le correspondant France Europe pour
bli bli qui a les petits petitte promo a
désormais son podcast Hebdo sur la
France que vous produisez enfin bonsoir
Louise coradiniir et bienvenue à vous
vous êtes la correspondante en France du
journal argentin la nation on va parler
tout à l'heure aussi de la victoire de
ravierre My élu président de l'Argentine
dimanche dernier Aquilino Morel ce débat
il est un peu fait pour vous si j'ose
dire puisqu'il prolonge directement
votre réflexion dans la parabole des
aveugles on commence par planter le
décor donc n'hésitez pas à intervenir he
c'est ce que je voulais dire on plante
le décor qui est-il ce Gert viders et
pourquoi il peut provoquer peut-être un
mouvement de bascule en Europe c'est
dans le chrono de blackco qu'on
accueille tout de
suite bonsoir mon cher Stéphane bonsoir
Miriam bonsoir à toutes et tous alors on
l'appelle le captaine peroxide j'ai
entendu votre question qui est Gert
wildilders c'est vrai que en France il
n'est pas du tout connu alors qu'au
Pays-Bas en revanche c'est vraiment un
vieux routier de la politique he qui
siège au parlement depuis 25 ans sa
première élection c'est en 98 alors il
était sous une étiquette de centre droit
tout à fait modérée la bascule pour lui
c'est 2004 lors de l'assassinat de Théo
Van Gog par un islamiste vous vous
souvenez peut-être de ça il avait donc
publié ce jour-là un tweet où il
s'engageait à dire librement ce qu'il
pensait de l'islam donc ça fait 20 ans
qu'il dit librement des insultes en
permanence sur l'islam au point qu'il
vit évidemment sous protection policière
alors je pourrais faire la liste de de
ces propos choquants je vous signale
simplement que en 2009 il a été refoulé
à Londres parce que ses propos sont
tellement excessifs que les Britanniques
craignaient que ça puisse créer des des
émeutes lors de sa venue alors
évidemment comment quelqu'un de SII
extrémiste a pu être arrivé en tête au
législativ au Pays-Bas donc faut quand
même reconnaître au départ qu'il y a un
problème de sécurité lié à l'immigration
au Pays-Bas qui est un des thèmes
évidemment de gu builders voyez vous
souvenez peut-être que l'an dernier une
trafiquant un gang marocain avait
carrément projeté d'enlever soit la
princesse héritière soit le premier
ministre pour faire libérer leur chef
qui étit en prison mais pourtant si
Gilders est arrivé en tête c'est pas
seulement parce que il a des propos
radicaux sur l'immigration ou sur
l'islam c'est même plutôt le contraire
qu'il a fait pendant la campagne il a
mis de côté tous ses propos où il
proposait de interdire le Coran fermer
les mosquées pour faire apparaître un
côté plus modéré je vous propose de
l'écouter les mosquées et le Coran est
un point crucial de notre campagne
est-ce que l'on dit que si nous ne
pouvons pas mettre en place ces mesures
nous ne gouvernerons pas la réponse est
non il y a d'autres points qui sont plus
importants voyez dans dans le fond enfin
il a suivi l'exemple donné en France par
Marine Le Pen en cherchant à ce
dédiaboler donc voilà c'est un mot que
j'ai du mal à dire merci de m et pendant
la campagne il a voilà pas mal accès sa
campagne sur pouvoir d'achat par exemple
il proposait de supprimer les taxes sur
l'essence comme Marine Le Pen donc ne
soyez pas étonnés si Marine Le peine se
réjouit de son succès on l'écoute je me
félicite de cette victoire parce que
Gelders c'est son mouvement sont des
alliés du rassemblement national il
participe du groupe identité et
démocratie au Parlement européen et il
démontre que de plus en plus de pays au
sein de l'Union européenne d'abord
conteste son fonctionnement et il y a
vraiment de quoi ah il y a vraiment de
quoi on sent qu'elle a une dent contre
l'Europe Marine Le Pen alors elle ne
propose plus de quitter l'Union
européenne comme c'était le cas jusqu'en
2017 en revanche lui g bildars reste
attaché à ça et ça faisait partie de son
programme de proposer un référendum sur
le maintien des Pays-Bas dans l'Union
européenne donc vous savez que dans
l'Union européenne dès qu'on parle de
référendum de maintien dans l'Union
c'est un peu la panique et effectivement
c'est ce que dit le Parisien sur frroide
à Bruxelles parce que au-delà de G
builders il y a une montée de la droite
nationale nationaliste même en Europe
donc ça c'est une carte où on voit la
représentation de la droite nationaliste
dans les parlements donc il y a plus
c'est bleu plus c'est à droite donc
voilà ça c'est bleu trè marine c'est la
Hongrie de Orban la Pologne qui a
pourtant où les majorité progressiste s
installé on voit que les conservateurs
sont encore très présents vous voyez que
il y a de l'extrême droite qui participe
en Finlande en Suède au gouvernement
c'est le cas aussi en Italie alors même
l'Allemagne VO qui est plutôt pas si
foncé que ça il y a 20 % d'intention de
vote pour la FD qui un parti néonazi un
parti vraiment d'extrême droit donc
forcément les partisans de l'Europe
s'inquièent d'autant plus que dans 6
mois ce sont les élections européennes
on écoute glxman c'est pour ça que tous
les mois qui vont venir l'élection qui
va venir elle est aussi essentielle
aussi fondamentale en fait on a jamais
eu un moment aussi décisif dans notre
histoire vous savez que aujourd'hui
Poutine est en train de gagner son Paris
son Paris c'était que si on met sous
pression l'Europe si on met l'Europe
dans une situation où elle est obligée
de se mobiliser elle n'y arrivera pas
bon ben voilà c'estu près tout ce que je
voulais de vous dire mais avec ce que je
viens de vous dire ce que vous
venezentendre il y a de quoi lancer un
Richard verli je commence avec vous j'ai
regardé quand même les les taux de
croissance et le chômage dans ce pays
les Pays-Bas et là on se dit ça fait
rêver franchement ils sont à 3 % de
chômage 4,5 % de croissance et pourtant
c'est l'extrême droite qui gagne comment
vous l'expliquez uniquement par les
fameux 3i insécurité immigration Islam
alors je rajouterai un élément c'est
l'usure du pouvoir Marc ruté le Premier
ministre qui a démiss é en juillet parce
qu'il n'arrivait pas à trouver une
majorité sur un nouveau texte législatif
consacré à l'immigration il est resté 10
ans au pouvoir donc c'est long il y
avait donc une usure personnelle liée à
ruté qu'on appelait Teflon Marc parce
que il arrivait toujours à s'en sortir B
cette fois ça n'a pas été le cas et puis
la deuxième chose c'est un affaissement
de la gauche et des verrs si vous
regardez le scrutin en fait il faut bien
sûr voir la victoire de gervilder mais
il faut regarder l'ensemble du spectre
et vous constatez que l'alliance entre
les travaillistes et les veres qui étit
mené par Fran timerman c'està-dire
l'ancien vi-président de la Commission
européenne chargé du Green Deal les
grandes ambitions écologiques de
l'Europe et bien il n'est qu'à 25 sièges
donc c'est c'est voilà les les trois
phénomènes je pense les 3i comme vous
l'avez dit sécurité immigration mais
aussi le l'usure de ruté et une gauche
qui n'est pas arrivée et là on trouvera
peut-être des parallèles avec la France
à apporté une alternative aux
préoccupations des électeurs néerlandais
y el Go il était ultra libéral ce gu
velders il est devenu un peu étatiste
voir très clairement enclin à ouvrir les
van de la dépense publique est-ce qu'il
s'est marinisé bah c'est ce que Marine
Le Pen dit en coulisse elle dit elle
remercie ger wildilders d'avoir erénisé
son programme c'està-dire d'avoir gardé
les piliers les trois i dont vous
parliez et notamment la lutte contre
l'immigration mais d'avoir ajouté du
social de la sécurité de la santé de
l'État providence peut-être fictif et
factice mais en tout cas c'est rajouter
dans le programme et la fin de campagne
de gervilders c'est ça il met un petit
peu de côté l'outrance quand même on se
souvient c'est quelqu'un qui compare le
le corant à mcampf quand même on est à
ce niveau de de violence verbale
idéologique et il ajoutent en fin de
campagne des choses qui sont beaucoup
plus sensibles pour les classes
populaires les classes moyennes
néerlandaises donc il y a cette il y a
cette dimension là et j'ai envie de dire
le libéralisme de gervilders n'a presque
rien à voir avec le l'étatisme de Marine
Le Pen il faut considérer que toutes ces
extrêmes droites qui ont le vent en
poupe et relativisant l'Espagne et
relativisant la Pologne quand même he on
pe pasou on peut pas faire une cographie
unique de ce qui le parti d'extrême
droite le PCE a perdu les dernières
élections en polne n'a rien à voir
Marine Le Pen reste quand même sur un
registre qui est très différent on se
demande ce que ces extrêmes droites ont
parfois à faire ensemble tellement leur
logiciel économique diffèrre donc c'est
vraiment sur des questions identitaires
qui rassemblement mais prenez Marine Le
Pen et Georgia Meloni c'est le grand
écart Georgia Meloni finalement s'est
européanisé malgré elle au contact du
pouvoir en en faisant adopter le le
pacte as d'immigration c'est c'est c'est
les eurodéputés de son camp ont voté au
Parlement européen pour ce pacte là que
Marine Le Pen conteste doncliste elle
est plutôt proukraine contrairement à
d'autres extrémistes eurir je me suis
écarté du du sujet pay restons sur les
Pays-Bas g vilders il a bénéficié du
carburant des autres tous les autres
partis quasiment autour de lui ses
adversaires ont repris l'argumentaire
anti-immigration donc finalement les
électeurs sont allés chercher l'original
et pas la copie et ça c'est exactement
la bascule qu'on est en train de vivre
en France avec Marine Le Pen c'est que
vous avez les LR lilipuiens aujourd'hui
la droite française qui court derrière
les mots et les arguments de Marine Le
Pen et qui lui fournit un carburant en
fait aujourd'hui c'est elle qui monte
avec d'autres supporters qui sont
censésêtre ses adversaires l'original
préféré à la copie Laurent Geoffrin sur
l'Europe là aussi on il y a des des
distinctions parce que ce ce vilders il
veut le nexit la sortie des Pays-Bas de
de l'Union européenne il veut faire un
un référendum là il y a une distinction
avec Marine Le Pen qui le souhaitait
mais qui ne le souhaite plus vous vous
voyez des des grands invariants chez ces
populistes venu de la droite radicale de
l'extrême droite est-ce que est-ce
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont en commun est-ce
que c'est immigration Islam insécurité
uniquement uniquement non mais
principalement oui principalement c'est
ce que la ce que les gens de gauche mes
amis refusent de voir ils expliquent
c'est à cause du social c'est à cause de
l'état providence qui fonctionne pas de
la crise économique que le chômage et
toute chose qui n'existe pratiquement
pas au Pays-Bas donc c'est un problème
là donc si on cherche une causalité
simple résumé c'est l'immigration
c'està-dire l'identité et la crainte
pour l'État providence c'est c'est les
deux et tant que la gauche refusera de
voir cette réalité elle se fera battre
non pas qu'il faille comme vous l'avez
dit reprendre le discours de du
rassemblement national en de l'extrême
droite ou des populistes il SAG pas du
toute à ça il faut assumer l'accueil
mais il faut que l'accueil
soit équilibré par un sentiment de
maîtrise c'est le point clé les gens ont
le sentiment qu'on ne maîtrise pas
l'immigration si on dit à la population
voilà l'immigration c'est juste c'est
utile regardez 30 % dans le bâtiment
c'est des gens qui viennent de
l'étranger les gens les services à la
personne ce sont des immigrés souvent et
les les travailleurs de première ligne
qu'on a vu qu'on a célébré pendant la
crise du covid se sont souvent des
immigrés gens comprennent bien qu'on en
a besoin et que on peut vivre avec eux
la preuve c'est qu'on le fait tous les
jours dans les entreprises et mélonie en
régularise en Italie parce qu'elle en a
besoin pour l'économie vieillissante et
une démographie quiine mais il y a un
corollaire à ce que je dis il faut dire
aux gens on on on contrôle h on maîtrise
d'abord il y a des conditions il y a des
conditions
d'entrée il faut s'intégrer à la la vie
sociale il faut apprendre la langue il
faut apprendre les valeurs de la société
il faut s'intégrer je ne dis pas
s'assimiler mais en tout cas s'intégrer
et deuxièmement le le les flux doivent
être maîtrisés on peut pas continuer à
dire il y a des lois en France il y a
des lois personne ne ne veut les les
bouleverser il y a des lois qui disent
on accueille les réfugiés et puis il y a
des règles et et ceux qui ne sont pas
dans les critères sont renvoyés chez eux
mais ils sont pas renvoyés donc les gens
se disent bon bah ils baratinent quoi
ils nous disent que maîtrisent il
maîtrisent rien et donc cette classe
politique est incompétente alors après
ça ça ça s'applique à d'autres sujets ce
sujet est central c'est directement
votre thèse vous vous êtes extrêmement
dur avec la gauche cette gauche morale
cette gauche du camp du Bien qui a
plongé presque autant que dans le dénis
pire alors là c'est c'est mais mais qui
aime bien châti bien vous vous pensez
vraiment que on paye quoi avec cette
montée des populismes un peu partout en
Europe une forme de cécité sur
l'identité ces questions liées à
l'identité même de l'Europe trois
petites remarques par rapport au débat
qui vient de se nouer si on a autant de
mal à caractériser
des groupes qui sont si différents et
qu'on les appelle néanmoins populisme
extrême droite c'est peut-être parce que
l'usage de ce mot populisme ne convient
pas c'est peut-être une manière très
commode alors justement un petit mot
caoutchou si que l'on peut tordre dans
tous les sens mais qui qu'est-ce qu'il
faut dire les populismes au pluriel au
minimum des populismes d'extrême gauche
de gauche radicale d'extrême droite et
même d'extrême centre je rappelle que le
Président de la République en 2017 s'est
présenté ouvertement comme un populiste
ça vous amuse mais c'est vrai je
rappelle antisystème plusieurs
déclarations si être populiste c'est
être proche du peuple l'écoutter alors
je suis populiste et cetera et on peut
pas dire qu'il n'a pas chevauché la
vague des gagistes donc c'est un mot qu'
est peut-être trop commode d'utiliser
hein on voit bien que le au Pays-Bas
c'est pas la même chose que qu'en France
parce que c'est pas du tout la même
histoire et on n'est pas du tout au au
même moment ensuite sur la question des
origines bien sûr qu' il y a
l'immigration et bien sûr qu'il faut la
contrôler ça et c'est pas seulement un
sentiment qu'on les gens qu'on
contrôleent pas c'est une réalité et
j'ajouteraiis puisque le mot a l'air de
de faire peur à Laurent geoffrein mais
ce qui est important dans l'immigration
c'est pas seulement de contrôler les
flux c'est de dire pourquoi on fait
venir des gens et on peut pas les faire
venir seulement parce qu'il sauraient ce
qui ne sont pas des bras ou des cerveaux
sont des êtres humains et lorsqu'ils
viennent il vienent avec leurs femmes
leurs enfants leur culture leur religion
leur histoire et d'ailleurs ils ont bien
raison donc l'objectif c'est
l'assimilation c'est de faire moi je
pense que chaque immigré chaque étranger
j'en ai été un qui vient en France doit
devenir franç
c'est ça l'objectif c'est d'ailleurs un
objectif magnifique si c'est un débat je
veux bien dire quelque chose allez-y
puis ensuite on fait circul vous pouvez
répondre rapidement ou disant que le trè
moteur qui existe pour le le vote
populiste entre guillemets pour utiliser
cette formule un peu facile bah c'est
pas seulement l'immigration c'est pas
seulement la pauvreté puisque par
exemple au Pays-Bas c'est pas un ressort
principal même si chez nous ça l'est
mais c'est bien sûr la question de
l'Union européenne et au Pays-Bas c'est
une question centrale dans le débat oui
que vous fustigez hein je fustige pas je
dis ce tournant
chos qu'il faut sur lesques il faut
revenir Laurent ja rapidement puis
ensuite on on va prendre un peu de de
hauteur sur le scrutin de juin
l'assimilation en fait c'est un mot
assez flou parce que qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire exactement ça veut dire qu'ils
doivent abandonner toute identité
particulière ils doivent abandonner leur
religion leur manière de de manger leur
manière de
s'habiller interdire les les foulards
dans la rue par exemple parce que c'est
c'est pas de l'assimilation vous l'aimez
pas ce terme là je pas qu'il soit
possibleon demande aux étrangers
d'abandonner toute tout toute
originalité toute personnalité à
l'entrée du pays non on on a jamais
demandé ça d'ailleurs on l' demandé à
mes parents et à des millionss ont voulu
le faire oui et bien c'est bien la
question la question c'est il s'agit pas
d'abandonner s'agit d'aller dans une
dire demand pas deabandonner on demande
de devenir français un français peut
être parfaitement musulman juif
catholique ça n'a aucune importance oui
mais à ce moment il aura des Meur
particulières bien entendu alors on va
on va continuer c'est intéressant parce
que voilà c'est pas nouveau he cette
bagarre sur C sur ces termes là oui
c'est vrai que c'est un point clé Louise
coradini quand on regarde on va
retrouver la carte qu'a montré Stéphane
tout à l'heure c'est la carte du des
poids électoraux des partis d'extrême
droite pour la plupart d'ailleurs tous
d'extrême droite pas de d'extrême gauche
dans dans dans ce qu'on a montré là on
se dit est-ce que en juin prochain il
pourrait y avoir par le jeu des
coalitions un nouveau por de force une
nouvelle majorité à Bruxelles entre
l'Union des droites une droite dure et
une droite extrême où est-ce qu'on joue
à se faire peur et c'est vraiment un
grand
danger bien sûr que si ça pourrait ça
pourrait exister et le problème c'est
l'équilibre de l'Europe qu'est-ce que
va-t-il se passer avec les équilibres
géopolitiques surtout de l'Europe que
va-t-il se passer vis-à-vis de de de la
guerre en Ukraine que va-t-il s'est
passé avec la Russie que va-t-il se
passer et n'imaginons pas si aux
États-Unis Trump gagne encore les
élections ça va être vraiment un are
monde moi je je préfère ne pas imaginer
mais il faudrait quand même se préparer
de toute manière moi je crois que en ce
qui concerne l'avance de l'extrême
droite on oublie une variable
fondamentale c'est l' sens du
déclassement des gens parce que euh ça
n'existe pas que en Europe ça existe
aussi partout en Amérique latine on va
peut-être parler
deartine alors quel est euh quelle est
la variable commun qui pourrait
expliquer cette avance partout dans le
monde et moi je pense que c'est beaucoup
plus sociologique que les problèmes de
des immigrés qui est naturellement est
normal mais les les hommes quand ils ont
problèmes quand ils ont des problèmes
quand ils ont des problèmes
d'intégration quand ils ont des
problèmes dans leur vie quotidienne ils
pensent toujours euh
que l'autre est l'infer donc il y a
toujours vot protestataire de
colèreavage et voilà mais le problème
est beaucoup plus profonde que ça je
pense que c'est vraiment les sentiments
de déclassement des petites classes
moyennes de beaucoup de gens des jeunes
qui n'ont pas de futur et ça
euh je ne sais pas si les gouvernements
sont capables des répondre à ce
phénomène fondamental et profond et
quelque chose d' extrêmement difficile
je suis très pessimiste parce que ça va
être la ligne de de fracture de de
clivage de la campagne en juin en gros
les quoi les nationalistes
eurosceptiques contre les progressistes
europhiles oui je pense qu'on a pointé
du doigt les deux grands thèmes le
premier thème ce sera l'immigration
c'est évident que sur ce thème-là les
partis que moi j'appelle
nationauppulistes au pluriel ils vont
ils vont foné parce qu'il voit que ça
rapporte des voix et en plus il ils
mettent le doigt sur des réalités que
les gouvernements actuels n'arrivent pas
à résoudre la meilleure preuve c'est que
le fameux pacte asile et immigration ce
paquet législatif européen il a été
présenté en 2020 et au jour où nous
parlons il na toujours pas été voté et
on n'est même pas sûr qu'il le sera
avant les prochaines élections
européennes donc premier point
immigration et deuxième point je reviens
vers ce que disait Akil Morel le
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne et
là il faut quand même dire une chose
c'est qu'on ne peut pas comparer la ce
qui se passe au Pays-Bas à ce qui se
passe par par exemple en Italie ou en
France pour une raison simple les
Pays-Bas sont un contributeur net à
l'Union européenne les Pays-Bas ils
paient pour l'Union européenne donc
c'est beaucoup plus facile pour lui
gertvilders de dire nous on veut plus
payer on veut plus payer pour des
programmes qui ne marchent pas Madame
mélony c'est plus compliqué parce
qu'elle elle reçoit donc il lui est
difficile de dire on ne veut plus
recevoir d'autant qu'il y a beaucoup
d'argent dans le pipeline donc autrement
dit lui il a vraiment je dirais tous les
arguments en tant que leader d'une
formation politique dans un pays riche
fondateur de l'Union européenne ça peut
être très dévastateur h il a go alors
c'est compliqué les partis en Europe
parce que c'est pas les mêmes que
évidemment dans nos pays est-ce que vous
pensez que au vu des différents rapports
de force de ces élections on peut
assister à une sorte d'union des droites
au niveau des des partis qui siègent non
pas par nationalité je le rappelle mais
par grands bloc par grandes familles
politiqu en Europe au Parlement oui
c'est on rentre un petit peu on va
zoomer un peu sur le Parlement européen
mais il y a deux extrêmes droites si on
peut résumer il y a deux groupes ECR et
le groupe identité démocratie ID qui se
qui se tire un peu la Bour il y a
concurrence vraiment entre ces deux ces
deux ces deux group prouve à quel point
ils sont divisés ger wildilders par
exemple est avec Marine Le Pen JAL Bard
là parce que Marine Le Pen ne siège plus
dans le groupe ID avec la FD également
qui est l'extrême droite allemande mais
cela ne se mélange pas avec ECR qui est
dominé par mélonie qui un peu faire de
lance de ce group là donc évidemment en
terme de vote ça peut tout à fait se
coaliser au Parlement européen et vous
avez une partie du PPE la droite
européenne Parti populaire européen qui
est tenté aussi par des forces
centrifuge d'aller vers là où est la
force aujourd'hui c'est dans ce vote là
ce vote de droit dur les députés d'Orban
ils sont au PPE aujourd'hui il est
possible que le 9 juin prochain après
c'est la campagne en Europe qu'il
décidera et la bataille d'argument que
apparaissent des minorités de blocage
dans le fonctionnement futur du
Parlement européen c'est que les
proeuropéens qu'il soient socialist
écologiste centriste ou de ou centre-
droit tous ensemble ne fassent pas
forcément le point le poids face à ces
votes là mais ça c'est de la pour
l'instant c'est de la
sur c'est exact ça va être
ça l'pé de Damocles de la campagne ça va
être ça c'est est-ce que oui ou non à la
fin on arrive à un Parlement européen
qui peut se retrouver bloqué par des
minorités de blocage et alors pour le
coup tout le fonctionnement remis en
question que ce soit sur les questions
climatiques que ce soit sur les
questions d'immigration de gestion
commune à 27 il il est là l'enjeu donc
on va avoir une bataille féroce qui n'a
pas commencé d'ailleurs juste une
parenthèse je trouve que le camp
d'Emmanuel Macron depuis quelques
semaines est très très mou sur sa
campagne européenne on a l'impression
que personne n'a envie d'aller d'aller
au charbon d'aller au combat aujourd'hui
Macron n pas encore apparu vraiment
là-dessus et puis c'est un concours de
défaut non je serai pas Têtre de liste
toi non plus BR le maire non et cetera
et ceteraab non la bataille mérite quand
même d'être menée beaucoup plus
férocement qu'elle ne l' aujourd'hui
à quoi elle peut ressembler alors cette
campagne Laurent jaoffrin avec ce risque
de
paralysie face à une vague eurosceptique
au Parlement depuis le brexit l'extrême
droite a changé al peut-être pas Vilder
ça je suis pas assez spécialiste pour le
dire mais l'extrême droite en général en
France en tout cas a changé elle est
plus elle veut toujours détruire
l'Europe ils sont ils sont nationalistes
ils veulent pas de l'Europe mais ils ne
veulent plus la détruire en la quittant
qu'il voit bien que la transformer de
l'intérieur pas populaire du tout ils
veulent la détruire de l'intérieur la
bloquer en fait bloquer les coopérations
et et surtout faire campagne ça c'est le
plus dangereux à mon avis faire campagne
contre toutes les conventions qu'on a pu
passer et qui protègeent les les les
droits individuels et les libertés
publiques ça c'est c'est leur cible il a
qu'à lire Le Figaro il y a enfin dans sa
partie la plus à droite et il y a qu'à
écouter toutes les leextrême droite ils
vous disent c'est le gouvernement des
juges c'est la supranationalité c'est
insupportable on peut pas euh faire ce
qu'on veut en matière de droit de
l'homme qu'est-ce que c'est que ça c'est
des abstractions qui compte c'est la
nation c'est l'adaptation de l'État de
droit
frempétat de droit par le la
souveraineté populaire par le par le
vote le référendum c'est ça le leur
nouvelle tactique et est plus
redoutablebl parce que du coup ceux d'en
face peuvent pas dire vous voulez
quitter l'Europe regardez les Anglais ça
marche pas ça puisqu'ils veulent pas
quitter l'Europe et pas le et Laurent
Geoffrin vous avez raison et cette cette
idéologie là a cont aminer la droite
républicaine française qui aujourd'hui
porte exactement les mêmes choses vous
verrez en mois de décembre là
prochainement une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle qui vise en fait à
sortir des traités européens et ça c'est
Eric cotti le renvoquer qui l'apporte et
le renvoquer lui-même qui aujourd'hui
mène la guerre contre l'État de droit et
les autorités indépendantes et cetera et
cetera alors je voudrais qu'on avance je
vous redonne la parole mais quand même
il faut qu'on parle de phénomène
populiste pas qu'en Europe parce que
c'est suffisamment important et ça s'est
produit cette semaine la question c'est
l'Argentine on l'appelle le Trump de la
Poma ravier M a été élu à une très large
majorité dans un pays écrasé par
l'inflation et la pauvreté son portrait
avec
elamondagava le soir de son élection
ravier M a troqué sa veste en cuir pour
un costume plus sérieux mais il n'a pas
mis de côté son Fran
parler
dimanche dernier l'Argentine a porté à
sa tête cet économiste de 53 ans
tendance
anarcoapitaliste c'est une joie
incroyable vraiment c'est la fin d'un
déclin sans fin alors au corrompu
dehors il n'est plus possible de vivre
avec les augmentations avec la violence
avec les voleurs qui entrent par une
porte et sortent par l'autre et les gens
voulit un
changement cheveux et bourrif allure de
Rockstar
on le surnomme le Donald Trump de la
[Applaudissements]
pampa mais si son style peut faire
sourire son programme lui inquiète son
emblème la tronçonneuse pour couper dans
toutes les dépenses le nouveau président
veut privatiser tout ce qui peut l'être
remplacer le Pau par le dollar supprimer
la Banque centrale du pays ultralibérale
sur le plan économique ultra
conservateur sur le plan social opposé à
l'avortement qu'il désigne comme un
assassinat aggravé par ascendant ravier
Miley veut supprimer le ministère du
droit des femmes et les cours
d'éducation sexuelle un programme plus
que radical qui a pourtant convaincu une
majorité d'argentin sensible à son
discours antiystème dans un pays écrasé
par une inflation à trois chiffres plus
140 % en
2023 lis scoradini
j'ai une question simple parce que
au-delà du portrait climatoseptique
antisystème ultraalibéral ultra
grrossier aussi la question c'est est-ce
qu'il est saint d'esprit est-ce qu'il
est fou ravier mileay ou pas s'il est
fou moi je crois que oui
mais de toute manière ce sont les
argentins qui l'ont choisi donc est-ce
que les Argentins sont fous aussi euh
mais r M est la preuve que tout
peut-être
pire on parle avec préoccupation de ce
qui arrive en Europe voyez ce qui se
passe en Argentine alors je crois que
c'est une mauvaise
définition que de dire que jaavier my
est un Trump des Pampas parce que ils
n'ont rien à voir alors la différence
voilà Javier my est un homme surgit de
nulle part un phénomène de la télévision
il a travaillé 15 ans à la télévision il
a appris tous les codes de la télévision
je l'appelle un personnage toc et et
c'est ça qui Trump aussi est venu passer
par la télévision pas que mais il avait
son show aussi ah oui mais il est
économiste il a été juste conseiller des
l'homme les plus riches de l'Argentine
mais il a ses revanche avec la Casta
comme ilappelle je vaux dire les les
castes dirigeant c'est vrai qu'il a
surgi rapidement aidé par qui qui l'a
financé qui qui lui a permis de faire
campagne
justement cet homme qui est propriétaire
des une énorme chaîne de télévision qui
s'appelle er kan il est le propriétaire
de tous les aéroports en Argentine et en
Amérique latine il a une corporation des
médias ce gigantesque il a travaillé
pendant 15 ans dans dans ses dans ses
médias et donc il s'est fait connaître
par ses autrances par ses insulte par
cette façon d'être par exemple il
apparaissait dans des plateaux de
télévision habillé un super-héros genre
homme aragé araigné avec tout masqué
avec son sa trançonneuse on voit les
outrances la trançonneuse pour
symboliser les coupes sombres dans les
dépenses publiques il suppriment un
maximum de ministères il remplace le
pesau par par le dollar alors quelle
conséquence mais ça c'est fondamental
dans dans dans dans la dans l'imaginaire
collectif pour les Argentins c'est
fondamental un pays qui a été gouverné
maltraité pendant 70 ans par le
peronisme le premier populisme en
Amérique latine et qui est devant 140 %
d'inflation
avec 4 millions de de pauvres de plus en
8 mois comme avait créé l'autre candidat
du ballotage qui était péroniste en fait
ministre de l'Économie ces gens tout
simplement pensait et on parlait de
déclassement tout à l'heure qui était
hors du monde l'Argentine était sortie
du monde elle n'existait plus alors
qu'est-ce que ça signifie que le dollars
le dollar est le moyen de revenir au
premier monde c'est pour ça que ce sont
surtout les jeunes et les petites
classes moyennes qui ont voté pour M qui
ont voté pour lui j'aimerais bien avoir
votre regard sur le phénomène Miley pour
terminer ce débat Richard verlier est-ce
que c'est pas Trump qui par cette
élection que personne n'avait vu venir
autorise ce genre de de de vot vote le
tout est permis est-ce qu'il a pas
ouvert les vannes au niveau mondial à
ces à ces irruptions de populistes ce
qui est certains je crois même si Louisa
notait les différences c'est qu'il y a
il y a des analogies qui sont
continentales entre l'Amérique du Sud et
et l'Amérique du Nord l'Amérique du Sud
regarde en permanence vers le nord et
tous les codes de Trump ont quand même
été pour certains importés par avier
Miley oui Trump a été l'homme qui a tout
bousculé et à partir de ce moment-là qui
permet beaucoup de choses cela dit on l'
ça a été à noté Gert wildilders il est
en politique depuis 25 ans Marine Le Pen
je ne vous fais pas le portrait on la
connaît quasiment depuis toujours
mélonie c'est aussi une vétéran de la
politique italienne donc on n'est pas en
Europe dans la même je dirais
configuration mais effectivement Trump a
ouvert les vannes une chose quand même
dans le cadre de il faudrait se poser la
question à qui va profiter le crime le
si l'on si l'on considère que son
élection va il veut privatiser qui va
acheter tout ce qui va être privatisé il
passe au dollar ça intéresse qui de
passer au dollars j'ai quand même
l'impression que la fameuse casse qu'il
dénonce en fait elle a intérêt à son
élection parce qu'elle ce sera la
première au guichet lorsqu'il s'agirait
d'acheter des sociétés privatisées je ne
sais pas si je me trompe Louisa donc il
faudrait qu'on creuse un petit peu pour
savoir qui a payé et qui aura intérêt je
remarque simplement que Marine Le Pen ne
commande pas cette élection ne félicite
pas en tout cas outre mesure ne parle
pas de mi comme d'un homologue futur au
contraire elle se tient à distance et ça
c'est très intéressant parce qu'elle a
compris de ses erreurs avec Trump vous
souvenez quand elle elle pleurait en bas
de la Trump Tower pour espérer voir
Donald et puis qu'elle l'a jamais vu
qu'il l'a snobé tout ça le Capitol et de
est un traumatisme aussi pour le RN qui
ne veut pas être associé à des à des
pchistes et donc elle se tient à
distance ça c'est intéressant parce que
finalement mi devient presque un contre
mododèle pour Marine Le Pen voulant
devenir président ah oui ça c'est sûr
qu'en terme de normalisation my c'est
c'est le contreexemple merci beaucoup on
s'arrête là on aurait pu continuer
longtemps c'était passionnant merci pour
ce beau décryptage vous restez avec moi
aqu kilino Morel dans une dizaine de
minutes les parties prix de nos
affranchis ce soir Bertrand Perrier va
revenir sur le duo day mais pas vraiment
convaincu par cette inclusion pour
trouver un emploi aux handicapés et puis
le mot de la semaine qu'a choisi
Mariette d'égrand c'est le mot
territoire à toutes les sauces
nationales et internationales cette
semaine et puis il est à Falco de quoi
nous parlez-vous ce vendredi dans Action
planè bah c'est un vendredi un peu
spécial parce que c'est le Black Friday
donc évidemment on parle publicité et
ben à tout à l'heure les amis à tout à
l'heure parce que maintenant c'est
l'heure de plonger dans la parabole des
aveugles chez Grasset votre livre aqu
kilino Morel c'est dans le tableau de
bruguel qu'on voit en couverture on
comprend très bien ce que vous voulez
nous faire comprendre attention nous
marchons tel des aveugle sans même nous
en rendre compte vers l'abîme regardez
c'est dans l'invitation de léoux et on
en parle tous les deux juste
après si on vous invite à kilino Morel
c'est parce que vous réglez ses comptes
à une gauche que vous connaissez bien
vous avez été la plume de Lionel Jospin
à Matignon avant de devenir un proche
conseiller de François Hollande à
l'Élysée vous le haut fonctionnaire et
médecin vous dressz dans votre dernier
livre la parabole des aveugles un
terrible réquisitoire contre votre
propre camp à l'origine selon vous du
délitement de la vie politique qui
profite donc au rassemblement national
retour sur une irrésistible ascension
nous sommes en 1983 l'année du tournant
libéral de François mitteran prince des
politiciens écrivez-vous qui porte le
projet d'une Europe fédérale je
considère la construction de l'Europe
économique et politique comme les chance
la chance principale de l'avenir
français une Europe construite par et
pour la dépolitisation dites-vous un
terro pour l'extrême droite qui s'empare
de thème que la gauche des laiss une
gauche qui s'enferme dans le dénis et
les bons mon sentiment expliquez-vous
quitte à instrumentaliser la Marche des
beurs avec SOS Racisme vous y voyez un
dispositif politicien et cynique conçu
pour ressouder la gauche en lui donnant
un ennemi commun le FN sans jamais
s'attaquer à la racine du mal que sont
l'immigration le chômage ou la
désindustrialisation résultat pour vous
le 21 avril 2002 c'est cette
décomposition politique qui s'étale au
grand jour énorme surprise Jean-Marie Le
Pen ti les conclusions
en me retirant de la vie politique un
choc pour la gauche que vous accusez
d'avoir abandonné la condition ouvrière
au profit des minorités ethniques
sexuelles ou de genre avec ce livre vous
appelez les forces politiques de votre
camp à reconnaître les fautes du passé
et à reprendre la nation au
rassemblement national alors aqu kilino
Morel à 40 mois de la présidentielle
reste une question qui peut incarner
cette gauche de la
reconquête réponse aujourd'hui personne
personne on va vous montrer on a on a
choisi quatre profils on a choisi de
vous montrer Bernard casneu Fabien
Roussel François Ruffin Jean-Luc
Mélenchon on aurait peut-être pu
rajouter François Hollande aucun de
ceuxa ne sont capables à votre avis de
reconquérir la gauche que vous appelez
de vos vœux une gauche qui se serait
enfin réveillée j'aimerais que que l'un
d'entre eux au moins on soit capable
mais pour réussir ce tour de force il
reste 40 mois c'est peu de faire revenir
à la gauche les catégories populaires
principalement les ouvriers les employés
qui ont été dégoûtés et qui se sont
détournés d'ell il faudrait et c'est le
préalable c'est le sens de mon livre
faudrait d'abord être capable d'un
minimum d'introspection et de faire son
m à coupp alors on y va sur le Diagnos
je n'entends je n'ai entendu aucun de
cela le faire le le seul peut-être je
partagerai de ce point de vue-là le le
jugement que le regretté Jacques Julier
avait fait sur lui le seul qui
aujourd'hui sauve l'honneur de la gauche
c'est Fabien Roussel mais il n'est pas
socialiste c'est peut-être aussi pour ça
ah oui parce que les socialistes n'ont
absolument aucune capacité à
l'autocritique et à l'inventaire
aujourd'hui pour vous aucune on est
passé du d'une époque où vous avez
montré des images de Lionel juspin en 95
juste avant la présidentielle il avait
expliqué que il était temps et que lui
il demand demandait de pouvoir exercer
son droit d'inventaire depuis quand à
maintenant c'est plus un droit c'est un
devoir d'inventaire qui depuis quand la
gauche a perdu les ouvriers depuis quand
la gauche a au fond abandonné
véritablement le peuple c'est un un
processus qui s'est étalé sur plusieurs
décennies c'est long mais le décrochage
initial c'est bien entendu le tournant
de mars 83 c'est le moment où François
militaan décide que bah le socialisme
qui lui a permis d'arriver à l'Élysée
c'est terminé il fait cette
mystification qui consiste à faire à
escamoter le socialisme et à faire
surgir l'européisme enfin cette cet
idole nouvelle qui est qui est l'Europe
vers laquelle tout le monde doit se
tourner et et que tout le monde doit
vénérer c'est à partir de ce moment-là
mais je vais répondre aussi plus
précisément quand on étudie les votes
des ouvriers à partir de
1995 le premier parti ouvrier c'est
devient le le Front national ce n'est
plus le le Parti
socialiste en
1981 70 % des ouvr ont voté Françis
militair au second tour en 2002 13 % et
déjà en 2002 le 21 avril 30 % des des
des ouvriers avaient voté pour
jean-marcê singlant avec les années
miteran avec François mitteran lui-même
l'apprenti sorcier au fond qui est le
premier responsable de cette poussée
d'abord de Jean-Marie Le Pen dans les
années 80 il a eu cette phrase quand on
y réfléchit 30 ans après c'est cidérant
vous le cité c'est une force comme les
autres il ne faut pas avoir peur du
Front national c'est lui qui au fond a
permis la banalisation le premier le le
premier et le plus grand banalisateur du
Front national c'est François mitteran
et là où il a été d'une habilité
extraordinaire et perverse c'est que
dans le même temps il a été le
diabolisateur suprême c'est lui qui un a
ouvert les portes de l'audiovisuel
publicique à Jean-Marie Le Pen il a fait
accéder à l'URE de vérité au Club de la
presse al des flagrant délire toutes les
émissions où il est apparu comme la bête
de scène qu'il était où il a pu faire
entendre ses idées et dans le même temps
Françis militéran faisait naître SOS
Racisme qui dont l'unique combat était
de mettre à terre du bien contre le C du
mal bien contre le du mal c'est le même
qui a qui a fait les deux choses c'est
François muteran pour vous la la gauche
n'a plus questionner l'immigration dans
son histoire l'immigration c'est une un
véritable sujet il y a pas pas un angle
mort sur l'immigration à gauche si on
reprend jores on peut trouver des
discours vous dites qu'aujourd'hui et
depuis quand cette questionlà est
asphyxiée par par la morale bah depuis
que par exemple on l'a vu à l'écran
depuis que le mouvement SOS Racisme et
arlem désir ont écrit puisqu'il il a il
l'a écrit et c'était le le comment dire
le l'axe de de leur idéologie ce n'est
l'immigration n'est pas un problème
c'est le racisme qui t en est un H donc
si si on dit ça et lorsqu'on dit ça on
on fait sortir l'immigration du champ
rationnel de la discussion politique
puisque évidemment il reste le racisme
et personne ne peut se revendiquer comme
raciste donc tous ceux qui disent et
aujourd'hui c'est devenu évidemment
comment dire complètement àront renversé
tous ceux qui disent aujourd'hui plus
une force qui dit le contraire il faut
maîtriser l'immigration alors ce sont
des racistes au sens d'arl désir alors
la diabolisation du rassemblement
national a conduit selon vous à
l'épuisement du Front républicain et à
l'exaspération de millions de Français
vous dites qu'il faut parler à ces
électeurs sans mépris sans les
infantilisés comment vous jugez la
position du gouvernement sur la présence
de Marine Le Pen dans la manifestation
contre l'antisémitisme le RN n'a pas sa
place dans les cortèges c'est ce qu'a
dit son porte-parole Olivier verrand
mais ça date de maintenant quelques
quelques semaines mais je vais répondre
plus précisément à ce que vous dites
avec des choses qui sont très faciles à
comprendre lorsque Jean-Marie Le Pen
s'est présenté à l'élection
présidentielle de 1974 il a recueilli
190000 voix 0,74 % en 81 il est même pas
capable de se présenter il a pas les 500
parrainages le 21 avril 2002 il obtient
4800000 voix 16 86 % des voix en juin en
mai 2022 Marine Le Pen a obtenu
13288686 voix c'est 41,45 % retenez ça
c'est 70 fois le score de son père en 74
tr fois le score du 21 avril donc quand
vous passez d'un groupuscule dirigé par
un marginal le FN et Jean-Marie Le Pen à
un parti qui est aujourd'hui un parti
quasiment interclassiste qui s'adresse
et qui obtient les voix de 13 a plus que
5 millions d'écarts entre
Mac peut plus dire vous êtes des
fascistes vous êtes des extrémistes
d'ailleurs le président de la République
a rappelé à la première ministre qu'on
ne pouvait pas dire à 13 millions de
Français qui avaient voté à Marine Le
Pen en 2022 qu'ils étaient des fascistes
ou des péténistes d'un conseil des
ministres mais il l'a dit ça été
rapporté alors aujourd'hui est-ce que
cette politique du NO passarane c'est un
peu ça altofascisme le fameux cordon
sanitaire on l'a vu qu'il était quand
même encore efficace parce que malgré
tout il s'est réveillé dans les TR les
de tours de la dernière élection
présidentielle au à la grande surprise
de Marine Le Pen et et d'une certaine
façon pour l'instant elle ne gagne pas
les élections elle n'a pas d'alliés
comment vous jugez la position du du
gouvernement reprise par Emmanuel Mac
qui est de dire le RN n'a pas sa place
dans ce type de cortège mais moi je
pense personnel mais d'autres personnes
partagent C cette analyse notamment
Serge clfeld qui lui est un chasseur de
naz qui a traqué toute sa vie lui
considère que ça les engage et que s'ils
sont là c'est déjà il considè que
lorsque la cause est supérieure et la
lutte contre le racisme l'antisémitisme
qui est de la haine à l'état brut qui
vise même pas une religion mais une
origine une culture une trajectoire est
un objectif prioritaire alors tout le
monde doit être accepté et d'ailleurs
pour manifester vous êtes pas obligé de
manifester si vous trouvez que la
personne qui qui est à côté de vous est
déplaisante vous pouvez parfaitement
vous mettre 50 m derrière 50 m devant
mais de dire à la fois la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme justifie une
manifestation de masse mais mais vous
vous n'y avez pas votre place me paraît
incohérent et Jean-Luc Mélenchon alors
vous faites vraiment le procès de la
gauche socialiste et miterandienne
Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous dites qu'il est
passé du côté obscur de la la frurce qui
est la sienne qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
j'ai écrit cette phrase avant les
événements du 7 octobreantobre bien
entendu le livre été terminé au mois de
septembre donc avant donc vous voyez que
je m'étais pas beaucoup trompé mais je
ne visais pas évidemment je pouvais pas
l'imaginer personne pouvait l'imaginer
son comportement ambigu et de moins en
moins ambigu par rapport à la question
des de des des crimes et des massacres
du 7 octobre je visais par là le fait
queon voyait bien que il était dans une
démarche où il tout en valorisant son
talent personnel d'analyste de stratège
de de de de tribun qui qui est
indignable il était en train de perdre
la possibilité de rassembler autour de
lui non seulement des électeurs de
gauche mais même des électeurs allant
au-delà puisque son objectif semble-t-il
ce serait quand même de se représenter à
l'élection présidentiel et que plutôt il
se raccornissait sur un électorat qu'il
connaît bien qui est celui qui l'a fait
obtenir beaucoup de députés dans des
quartiers où l'immigration est très
forte la s s et ailleurs et que c'est à
mon sens ça c'est effectivement c'est
passé du côté obscur de sa propre force
car sa force elle existe mais il ne s'en
sert pas pour rassembler il s'en sert
pour conforter des bastions qui qui
n'ont d'ailleurs guerre besoin de l'IDRE
puisquils votent déjà à 60 % pour pour
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ou pour le LFI vous
expliquez très bien d'ailleurs que pour
vous le piège du rassemblement national
tendu il y a 30 ans par François
mitteran et bien Emmanuel Macron est
tombé dedans quel sursaut quel sursaut
vous parlez d'une union nationale c'est
ma dernière question contre le RN une
forme d'accord de toutes les forces
politiques contre le RN pas une union
nationale un sursaut national
c'est-à-dire que je pense que vous voyez
bien tout à l'heure on le montrait
aujourd'hui aucune des forces politiques
prises isolément ni la gauche qui est
complètement pulvérisée ni la droite qui
est complètement tassée n'est capable de
barrer la route à Marine Le Pen alors
alors alors d'un mot il faut que tous
ces gens-l se mettent d'accord sur un
programme minimal d'action sur les trois
thèmes qui taraudent le pays et et qui
alimente le vote RN c'est-à-dire le
déclassement on en parlait tout à
l'heure la pauvreté et la
désindustrialisation qui sont des plaies
terribles l'immigration du fait accompli
et le sentiment de dilution d'une France
dans une Europe de plus en plus
fédéralisée c'est sur ce programme là
qu'il faut s'entendre et agir car le
temps est compté désormais et j'invite
nos téléspectateurs à poursuivre ce
dialogue en lisant la parabole des
aveugles Marine Le Pen aux portes de
l'Élysée c'est chez Grasset vous restez
avec moi aquiline c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos parties prix nos
affranchis ils vont vous faire réagir
avec leur chronique on les accueille
tout de
suite le duo du vendredi Mariette
d'égrand notre sémiologue qui décortique
un mot chaque semaine et maître Bertrand
Perrier pour un billet d'humeur à saler
à souhait je l'espère préparez-vous on
commence avec vous Léa Falco vous
vouliez revenir sur ce spot de l'Adème
un spot décroissant qui n'a pas plu à
tout le monde et plus spécifiquement sur
ce qu'il y a derrière toute cette Ré
question gouvernementale à ce spot
c'est-à-dire la question de la publicité
aujourd'hui on en parle assez peu mais
en fait c'est une des grandes
contradictions de notre société d'un
côté on a en France des engagements
maintenant étatiques sur les questions
notamment de réchauffement climatique
qui vont impliquer d'une manière ou
d'une autre la réduction de la
consommation et pourtant à côté en tant
que consommateur en tant que citoyen on
est matraqué chaque jour par à peu près
1200 pubs en moyenne rien que ça qui
vont évidemment nous inciter à consommer
et ce que ce que vendent ces pub là
c'est aussi un idéal c'est aussi la
consommation comme acte de réussite
sociale parce que il y a une vocation
informative évidemment de la pub
c'està-dire vous faire savoir que le
produit existe mais il y a aussi une
vocation persuasive vous convaincre que
ce produit-là va rendre votre vie plus
cool plus sympa et donc que c'est
important de l'acquérir c'est comme ça
par ailleurs qu'on se retrouve avec des
pubs par exemple pour des SUV qui sont
lourds et énergivor et qui se baladent
en pleine montagne ou alors dans des
déserts alors que dans la vraie vie ils
sont plus souvent coincés dans des
embouteillages qu'autre chose alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on dim la pub et
ben c'est possible au moins au niveau
local sur l'espace public il y a des
règlements locaux de la publicité qui
sont assez peu usités aujourd'hui hein
mais Lyon par exemple en a édicté un et
va réduire de 60 à 90 % le nombre de
panneaux publicitaires dans la ville bon
c'est un premier axe ça a été lourdement
exploré par tout un tas de de
dispositifs la convention citoyenne pour
le climat d' y a quelques années avait
fait figurer dans ses recommandations
finale la réduction drastique de la
publicité pour je cite éviter une
incitation quotidienne et non cho is à
la consommation mais sans effet parce
qu'il faut aussi rappeler que derrière
le le l'industrie de la publicité il y a
des forts intérêts industriel en France
en 2019 c'est 34 milliards d'euros
investis dans la publicité et dans
beaucoup de secteurs qui sont soit
défavoraable à notre santé notamment les
fast food et la nourriture très grasse
ou à l'habitabilité des conditions de
notre planète la fast fashion l'aviation
lowcost et cetera donc derrière c'est un
vrai problème parce que on arrive à
quelque chose qui va être fondamental
dans la perception qu'on va avoir de de
ce qui est désirable à l'avenir et les
interdictions sur la publicité ça existe
déjà en France on a la loi Évin
notamment qui interdit la publicité sur
le tabac sur l'alcool donc c'est
possible et en plus pardon je me pose la
question mais qui apprécie la publicité
au quotidien partout autour de nous en
permanence 79 % des Français considèent
qu'il y en a trop 95 % qu'elle est
envahissante et plus de la moitié 65 %
exactement serait prê à interdire la
publicité pour les produits qui
contribuent au réchauffement climatique
donc nonen déplaise au gouvernement qui
effectivement est aux abois pour une une
publicité de l'ADEM qui incite à
repenser ces modes de consommation même
pas à interdire la publicité oui les
fameux dévendeurs qui déconseille
d'acheter il déconseille d'acheter quand
on n'a pas usage d'un outil par exemple
une ponceuse mieux vaut effectivement
l'allouer plutôt qu'autre chose et ben
malgré ça il faudra très probablement
dans les prochaines années réduire ce
qui est une véritable emprise
aujourd'hui de la publicité sur nos
cerveaux merci merci beaucoup Léa Falco
vous l'avez vu ce spot je l'ai vu mais
on voit bien que le gouvernement est
très embarrassé puisque aujourd'hui la
croissance est en train de de s'effondré
donc toute mesure qui permettrait de
relancer par la consommation positive et
en même temps à moyen long terme
l'objectif que vous rappelez c'estàd de
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique devrait emporter tout autre
considération mais là le nez dans le
guidon on a besoin d'essayer de trouver
quel fin du monde fin du mois ça demande
encore un autre débat on enchaîne avec
vous Bertrand voulez revenir sur le duod
qui s'est tenu hier oui c'était la 6e
édition de cette opération dite duodet
cette journée au cours de laquelle les
collectivités publiques les association
et les entreprises privées également
sont invité à accueillir des personnes
en situation de handicap qui vont former
donc un duo avec une personne valide et
les deux personnes vont passer la
journée ensemble il s'agit en quelque
sorte d'assurer une expérience immersive
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap dans le monde du travail avec
l'espoir que elles vont peut-être
trouver un emploi et de fait dans 20 %
des cas eu ça débouche sur une offre de
stage de CDD ou de CDI il faut quand
même savoir que c'est un réel succès il
y a eu presque 30000 binômes handivalid
hier dans notre pays mais vous y voyez
aussi une opération de com ou pas oui
alors il suffisait d'aller sur les
réseaux sociaux hier c'était absolument
frappant il n'y avait pas un ministre
pas un parlementaire pas un journaliste
qui ne se mettait en scène avec la
personne en situation de handicap qu'il
ou elle avait accueillli le président de
la République la première ministre
Clément bon Fran rester évidemment fatil
catabi qui est la ministre en charge des
personnes handicapé et donc évidemment
il y a dans cette journée un petit côté
trompeleuil aussi cette journée ne nous
exonère pas de nos obligations en terme
d'insertion sur le marché du travail des
personnes en situation de handicap les
364 autre jours de l'année il faut dire
que les discriminations demeurent
largement dans notre société notamment
dans l'accès à l'emploi oui le taux de
chômage des personnes en situation de
handicap dans notre pays est de 12 % ce
qui est quasiment deux fois plus que la
moyenne générale et il y a des emplois
qui sont aussi plus précaires qui sont
souvent dans un secteur protégé alors
que les personnes pourraient accéder à
un secteur classique et même si le taux
de chômage c'est vrai est en baisse la
durée de chômage est plus importante on
est quand on est en situation de
handicap au chômage aussi plus âgés avec
des difficultés dans le retour à
l'emploi et finalement beaucoup de
personnes en situation de handicap
renoncent à chercher un emploi et
sortent en quelque sorte des
statistiques mais si on fait le taux
d'emploi c'està-dire le rapport entre le
nombre de personnes handicapées et le
nombre de personnes qui travaillent en
situation de handicap ce taux est très
faible c'est 38 % donc en gros il y a
une personne en situation dans cap sur
trois qui travaillent dans notre paysoup
mieux on peut beaucoup mieux faire
depuis 19 7 vous savez il y a une loi
qui est le fameux quotat des 6 % les
entreprises de plus de 20 salariés
doivent embaucher 6 % de personnes en
capap en réalité seul 30 % des
entreprises concernées respectent la loi
les autres payent la contribution
financière équivalente ce qui n'est pas
satisfaisant on a besoin que ces
personnes aient un emploi non pas que la
GFI perçoive ce qui est un moindre mal
cette allocation il faut bien comprendre
que malgré tout cette question du
handicap touche 12 millions de personnes
en France c'est une question absolument
majeure il y a 3 millions de personnes
qui sont en situation d'être Activ et
qui sont porteuse d' handicap et
notamment d'un handicap invisible c'est
très important bien sûr il y a des
personnes qui ont des difficultés avec
l'accessibilité tout ça il faut pas
oublier les personnes qui ont un
handicap invisible il y a beaucoup de
progrès à faire sur l'aménagement des
postes de travail donc ce que je voulais
dire c'est que la photo pour le duod
c'est bien mais un contrat de travail
c'est mieux merci et c'est dit avec le
cœur merci beaucoup maître berartrand
Perrier on va enchaîner avec votre
chronique le mot de la scène ça va vous
intéresser vous en parlez d'ailleurs de
votre dans votre lire ce mot c'est
territoire il vous agace ce mot vous lui
préférez la province Mariette vous avez
retenu territoire parce que on en parle
les territoires occupés en six jordaniie
notamment mais aussi en France à propos
de certains faits divers oui ce mot est
dans l'air ce mot est monté et moi non
plus je ne l'aime pas ce mot mais je
dois dire que je l'ai vu arrivé j'avais
une certaine vague méfiance j'ai pas
creusé mais l'actualité et cette
chronique m'a obligé à le faire et j'ai
compris pourquoi je ne l'imis pas c'est
qu'en fait il est très guerrier un
territoire ça se prend ou ça se défend
toujours avec des moyens plus ou moins
violents et puis ce mot est très
hypocrite en fait il se donne à nous
sous un jour sympathique moderne on ne
dit plus province on ne dit même plus
région il faut dire la France des
territoires donc bah il se met dans
l'écosystème de la nature de la
champagne c'est un peu potager bio ça va
avec tout ça donc il a quelque chose
très authentique même un peu rocailleux
c'est vrai et moi je me souviens d'un
premier ministre Jean Castex à la
tribune de l'Assemblée nationale qui l'a
répété mais je ne sais plus combien de
de fois c'était son mantra avec son
accent du sud les territoires exactement
et donc là je crois que dans notre
imaginaire commun on mélange deux choses
on mélange territoire et terroir comme
s'ils avaient la même racine c'est pas
le cas alors c'est pas tout à fait le
cas c'est tout à fait ambigu en fait il
y a deux racines qui s'amalgament Terra
bah la terre bien sûr mais
malheureusement il y a une deuxième
racine qui est beaucoup moins
sympathique qui est le la terror et euh
le la notion latine de territorium ben
en fait elle mélange les deux et les
Romains eux-mêmes par exemple quand ils
annexaient une terre avec violence hein
et bien ils parlent de il ne disait pas
terrifier mais en fait il disait Terra
un peu comme alibi et donc ça nous en
sommes complètement les héritiers et il
y a même eu dans le droit euh médiéval
ch Bertrand la you terindi c'est-à-dire
le droit de terrifier donc on prenait on
pouvait organiser un espace par violence
avec un droit de terrifier c'est quand
même absolument abominable la terreur
française s'en est bien servi et euh mon
impression c'est que effectivement
l'actualité internationale où
effectivement nous certains faits divers
nous font penser que ce droit de
terrifier euh est revenu voilà et
dernier point pour éclairer pour
remettre une couche négative sur ce mot
c'est la langue il est dans la langue
des éthologues c'est-à-dire des gens qui
observent les grands fauves qui marquent
leur territoire ou bien les grands
oiseaux et là les grands oiseaux bah ils
sont pas sur la terre ils sont dans le
ciel donc on voit bien que territoire se
détache de la terre en revanche un
dernier mot qui est dans son écosystème
c'est le mot terrible qui aujourd'hui
est un peu mou mais qui au départ et
voulait dire terrifiant donc pour moi
dans tout territoire il y a quelque
chose de terrifiant c'est-à-dire de
profondément potentiellement violent
passionnant l'itinéraire d'un mot ça
vous parle d'un mot j'ignoris cette ce
rapprochement avec l'idée de terreur et
de terrible en revanche je partage tout
à fait ce que vous disiez c'est-à-dire
c'est un mot hypocrite et un mot comme
je le disais tout à l'heure à propos du
populisme caoutchou c'est vous pouvez le
tordre dans le sens que vous voulez le
territoire ça peut êtreunion européenne
la France une commune ou alt département
oui c'est ce sont des mots qui c'est de
la presque de la Neuve langue merci
beaucoup on s'arrête là merci pour vos
chroniques Léa Falco Mariette d'argrand
Bertrand Perrier et merci à vous à
Kiline Morel d'être venue nous voir sur
LCP la des aveugles c'est à lire donc
chez Grasset Marine Le Pen aux portes de
l'Élysée c'est la fin de cette émission
la fin d'une belle semaine merci à
toutes les équipes de la Chaîne
parlementaire qui ont rendu possible ces
émissions très belle soirée c'est le
weekend profitez bien à la semaine
[Musique]
prochaine